and the Prime Minister has confirmed  plans to send tanks to Ukraine he's had  a phone call with Ukraine's President  Vladimir zielinski A Downing Street  spokesperson has said that the leaders  agreed on the need to seize on this  moment with an acceleration of global  Military and diplomatic support to  Ukraine the Prime Minister outlined the  UK's ambition to intensify our support  to Ukraine including through the  provision of Challenger two tanks and  additional artillery systems and we are  apparently getting rid of those  Challenger 2 tanks  he has tweeted he said always strong  support  of the UK is now impenetrable and ready  for challenges